vingt ans après être apparue pour la
toute première fois sur les écrans de
télévision de millions de français
loana est encore et toujours une
personnalité scrutées par les journaux
people
il faut dire qu'elle est devenue la
toute première star de télé réalité
française en faisant son entrée dans
l'émission événement love story en avril
2001 loana 23 ans
depuis cinq ans elle est gogo dancer un
succès populaire gigantesque qui se
construira en quelques semaines
seulement des jeunes gens jusque là
anonyme propulsé au rang de star
c'est la sortie tous les docteurs avec
les vainqueurs sauf que voilà cette
fulgurante notoriété a été aussi
puissants vers le haut qu'elle n'est
aujourd'hui violente vers le bas après
avoir surfé sur ce succès depuis
plusieurs années lohan a fait l'objet
d'une véritable descente aux enfers je
passe 1 38 à 1 46 leurs offres et quand
je vois ne correspond pas je me
reconnais pas entreprise de poids cure
de désintox addiction aux drogues et
même des pressions la jeune femme
reconnaît elle même être dépassé par ses
démons de la présence énorme l'an mil
kamara 28 ans beaucoup dans le taxi
début septembre elle posté déjà une
vidéo dans laquelle elle indiqué se
sentir très mal et avoir passé son
anniversaire tout seul certaines salles
j'ai fêté l'anniversaire salle avait il
ya quelques jours ce sont carrément des
photos de son corps couvert d'hématomes
qui a publié des photos qui serait la
conséquence de violences conjugales
selon ses dires des catastrophes en
cascade et une vie pour le moins agitée
mais une question se pose aujourd'hui à
faire loana la télé réalité est-elle
fautive de son état
et on à sa mesure avec nos journalistes
people merci sam d'être là mais un jour
cyril merci pour votre invitation à tous
ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils aient toutes
les infos frais de cauvel ex petit
copain de loana merci d'être là
également pour agir sur les éléments
dont vous êtes accusé nous ici on y ont
ni très fan de loi d'angoulême beaucoup
c'est vraiment j'ai d'ailleurs de tpm p
c'est une jeune femme que j'aime
énormément parce qu'elle ait laissé un
amour à être là je vous le dis c'est
vraiment un a besoin on avait même prévu
un moment elle devait peut-être nous
rejoindre dans les pays acp de dia de
saison et voilà rouler on les aime
énormément alors c'est vrai qu'on
aimerait c'est que vos relations avec
loana maintenant je sais que vous êtes
vraiment son ex où il se passe quoi
oui je suis vraiment son ex on a plus
des relations amicales mais oui cdc des
relations amicales de qu'elle a besoin
de moi je suis là je m'appelle je vous
êtes rencontrés comment on s'est
rencontrés juste après le loft en fête
dans une boîte de nuit très qu'il ya
très longtemps alors arrivé en 2002 ou
2003 ans a rencontré ensuite on peut
être une industrie mettre en couple
ensemble en 2013 je crois adacore d'une
rentrée oui c'est ça et on est resté
trois ans ensemble
alors donc c'est en 2013 que début de
votre histoire et qu'elle très vite on
vous reproche d'être avec elle pour lui
pour l'argent oui mais c'est encore une
fois ça me fait rigoler parce que je
gagnais très bien ma vie à l'époque
s'est elle-même
j'avais une grosse entreprise de
climatisation corps voilà et je faisais
aussi beaucoup de photos pour des
magazines tout comme ça lâche un ancien
sportif j'ai fait beaucoup de photos
pour l'un des magazines de sport et je
gagnais très bien ma vie à l'époque qui
accueille justement c'est elle même qui
avait des problèmes d'argent puisqu'elle
était obligé de vendre son appartement à
paris parce qu'elle devait de l'argent
aux impôts donc c'est moi même à
l'époque qui l'avaient aidée non cas
alors vous êtes séparés plein de fois
savais que c'était des feux de l'amour
et on peut pas non plus rentrer c'est
vrai est l'histoire de couples un série
de ça ça concerne minera que vous et on
peut pas rentrer nommée elle vous
accusera de violences morales physiques
plusieurs fois avant vous remettiez
ensemble qu'est ce que vous répondez à
tout s'est alors il ya eu beaucoup de
violences verbales mais physique non
physiques non sagem été approuvé je suis
pas quelqu'un de violent envers une
femme c'est grave
les accueillir les accusations qu'elle
me porte c'est extrêmement grave où ces
photos là qu'on voit qui est là qu'elle
a postée sur un site assez pour plaire
elle dit à l'appel est clairement elle
dit clairement fait que soit disant je
l'aurais tabassés pendant quatre heures
honnêtement j'en ancien sportif si je
réellement j'avais tabasser par an
quatre heures c'est pas des bleus
qu'elle aurait eue alors étant moudenc
quand on voit ces photos si on a la même
et non moi le premier mal moi un premier
jeu j'aurais été inquiet aussi mais ces
sites vous l'avez au téléphone depuis
alors ou gelée beaucoup par sms en fait
elle m'envoie des deux puits vous l'avez
vu passer bien sûr parce que je lui ai
proposé de et vous lui dites quoi quand
elle dit que c'est vous qui le dit plus
non le dis plus elle est passée à autre
chose elle ne dit pas moi c'est en
parallèle elle laisse les publications
sur facebook et sur un ca g
là je ne comprends pas du tout non plus
par contre en parallèle allemand boit
deux messages très mignon très gentils
comme quoi que je lui manque
comme quoi enfin voilà elle c'est le
petit résumé de loana statut m'énerve je
t'aime je te déteste moi l'amour ne me
touche pas à ça c'est le résumé de loi
là mais à la date juste juste c'est vrai
que peut-être qu'elle est allée à
l'amoureuse de vous tous que ce soit on
est juste inquiet pour luan a bien sûr
ce que c'est vrai que c'est quand même
si comme vous disais ça ne vous disiez
ça me dira c'est la plus grande star de
télé réalité de la création id en
intégralité
nabila et loana qui était la première
c'est la plus iconique et on est tous
inquiet pour aidants alors grande je
sais pas parce que c'est une grande star
une petite salle je sais pas comment on
peut le mesurer
mais par contre en tout cas c'est la
star de télé réalité i coni pour moi
elle est le christophe colomb de la télé
réalité parce que c'est elle comme elle
a fait découvrir le genre oui à toute
une génération est aujourd'hui qu'on le
veuille ou non il ya énormément de
candidats télé réalité pour qui elle est
elle était une référence d'accor alors
que vous avez des nouvelles d'elle alors
moi les dernières nouvelles que j'ai
eues date de cet été il faut savoir
qu'on est régulièrement en contact
elle est d'accord c'est comme comme
artiste syrie qui peut permettre de
tutoyer je suis vraiment bon c'est un
amour elle envoie un petit message pour
le nouvel an pour noël l'adorable elle
m'a invité donc à son anniversaire qui
le 30 août qu'elle fêtait le 29
elle me disait donc sur what's app j'ai
loué une super maison avec un jacuzzi
il va y avoir plein d'alcool on va
pouvoir boire torelli et moi ce qui m'a
fait peur et ce jour là j'étais à
montpellier en vacances chez interstices
parce que rené popote massa je sais pas
c'est très grave au pastis avec
modération
elle mettait dans le message jusqu'à ce
que mort s'ensuive
et ça moi ça m'a complètement bouleversé
je suis allé voir ma mère je dis maman
est ce que tu entends la même chose que
moi
est ce que tu entends ça comme un appel
à l'aide c'est quoi je me fais une idée
et c'est une expression qu'on dit moi
personnellement je ne dirais pas ça je
me suis inquiété je vais envoyer des
messages envoyés dès whatsapp mais j'ai
l'impression que quand on essaie de
venir en aide à loana elle bloque
elle refuse tout dialogue comme si elle
avait besoin de lancer des appels à
l'aide de de donner de ses nouvelles sur
les réseaux sociaux sûr mais quand on
veut l'aider on ne peut pas je voulais
aller la voir je voulais prendre la
voiture même si j'ai pas le permis mon
copain m'a emmené et je serais allé la
voir et je dois vraiment remonter le
moral mais c'était impossible
elle ne répondait plus benjamin voulait
pas mais pour loana après vous étant ce
qu'elle est un peu à la castagne nom a
pas du tout pas du tout la cassagne
n'avaient pas été entendus programme de
violence violence henri jammet envers
une falaise de là mais vous savez jamais
si on m'insulte dans la rue je vais
tourner le dos à personne oui mais on
vers une femme jamais non c'était en
2013 pour abus de confiance il semble
que le procureur de la république a
ouvert une enquête
en 2000 il ya plutôt brillé plus dur que
jamais pour une violence physique envers
du service violences et abus de
confiance en vue son plan de lutte rasé
juste de levallois n'a vous la
connaissez bien géré la limmat le rôle
de lana et je pense que il ya par contre
et c'est que l es tu déjà fragile avoir
même de faire les matériaux extrêmement
projet extrêmement fragile mais bien sûr
que le vrai problème c'est que a d'abord
elle était pionnière personne ne savait
où on allait préchacquois quand même si
selon ses missions c'est tout nouveau et
c'est vrai que cette cette personne on a
très vite compris nous parce qu'on avait
toutes les images en entendez tous
qu'elle avait de vrais problèmes
psychologiques à l'été elle était
tellement anorexique lcds vais vomir
c'est la d'observer voilà le moi je
quand vous de la question est est-ce
qu'on est ce qu on est fautifs moi je
pense qu'effectivement km de wana
on est vraiment faut-il parce que cette
personne a été laissés livrés mais s'ils
arrêtent de dire non à temps complet de
le dire on écoute moi et après on en
parle est là les délais c'est vraiment
ça alors on l'a on l'a exploité on
l'avait gardée des émissions à la pas
été aidé ni psychologiquement avec aucun
soutien on peut pas créer une personne
comme ça qui est passé de l'ombre à la
lumière comme ça en un clin d'oeil et
l'a laissée vide tout seul mais c'est
pas possible
jean pascal oui même bateau tout le fer
entre will not a été de présenter oui
mais oui je suis la rade que s'il
sortait c'était oui mais c'était pareil
schéma je crois qu'aujourd'hui le
problème qui a série k à la sortie c'est
les premières années il n'y a pas de
suivi
d'accord c'est exact mais attention mais
il faut aussi savoir qu'on est confronté
à différentes choses en sorte
mais il faut aussi entre guillemets
excusez moi mais s'accrocher un peu et
pas tomber si on te dis attention là tu
peux tomber c'est le vide et si tu
marches là il faut pas se jeter dans le
gouffre il ya la drogue à tout ça mais
il faut aussi
non mais donc ok il faut aider les gens
mais c'est je veux dire vivre avec toi
tu es sauveteurs en mer qui est fait est
fait puisque logiquement n'était pas
fragile du tout donc la star ac vu ton
passé et voilà ça pouvais pas te faire
de mal l on savait très bien qu'elle
était quand même me fera les messages et
alors elle s'est laissé tenter lanson
mais je pense que sur la fin des
produits en jeu remportée gogo danseuse
à son arrivée non dans le loft
isabelle tous mes potes et l'avait déjà
elle avait déjà d'ailleurs on entend
dans le loft elle est effectivement gogo
danseur avant que tu ne peux pas non
plus aidé à outrance quelqu'un qui ne
veut pas être aidé ce soir c'est moi je
me souviens qu'à la sortie contre moi ce
que tu dis est une psy qui s'est proposé
moi j'étais là quand l'eau a indiqué
j'en avais pas besoin
et donc après tu peux pas lui tenir la
main toute la journée est-ce que je suis
triste pour elle oui est ce que je me
sens coupable pour est non alors fred
cauvin vous êtes ce soir et de
nombreuses fois avec loana vous raconter
avoir déjà levé la main sur elle
effectivement mois de février
mi février oui on peut pas l'accepter ça
freine non mais c'est vrai je suis
entièrement d'accord mais cgt c'était
une accumulation de fatigue en fête ou
auxquels la prenait énormément de
produits
je le cite je le reconnais mais justin
je m'en veux vraiment beaucoup
mais le problème c'est qu'il ya quand
vous avez une femme qui est agitée
j'ai très mal réagi avec la fatigue j'ai
très mal réagi je le reconnais j'aurais
pas dû leur école elle avait porté
plainte effectivement mais ça a donné
quoi
alors j'ai fait 48 heures de garde à vue
parce qu'il y avait d'autres petites
choses à côté comme la police est
intervenue dans son appartement qu'ils
ont retrouvé des drogues elle elle est
partie 12 heures en garde à vue pour
détention de stupéfiants à domicile et
moi je suis partie pour andrew des clubs
fonctionnent aujourd'hui en fait vous
voulez l'aider ou l'accabler ccoo alors
j'étais très en colère au départ mais
maintenant je j'ai changé de fusil
d'épaulé
je vais continuer à l'aider je vais
l'aider mais c'est quoi l'idée en fait à
pratiquement moralement là je lui
proposais de lui payer quelques jours de
vacances à deauville pour qu'elle aille
se reposer dans un sens mais vous
pourriez pas que vous êtes toxiques pour
elle mais qu'il faut juste justement que
vous l'ayez plus du tout contact avec
est pour ce serait la bonne idée de nom
mais bien sûr mais après c'est des
contacts à distance que j'ai envoyé
quelques jours on appelait on m'a dit à
l'apurement dans son frigo j'ai envoyé
un ami laurent amar qui a monté les
marches de de cannes avec est d'ailleurs
et il a été lui apporter des souhaits
j'étais lui rembourser le lendemain je
me la laisser ces questions un cobaye
d'une expérience on a entendu c'est
quand même très grave ce qu'on a entendu
si on fait quand vous dites
j'étais fatigué j'ai levé la main sur
elle si on peut pas laisser passer la
dent d'ailleurs il ya eu une gifle que
vous reconnaissez c'est le seul fait de
violence que vous reconnaissez et il y a
eu une plainte est une mesure
d'éloignement prises à une mesure
d'éloignement également sur d'éloigner
au mois juin c'est une sanction de la
justice sur vous devez être éloigné
d'elle de l'année ce que vous ne pensez
pas que cet éloignement il induit aussi
ce que disait syrie c'est à dire est ce
qu'il faudrait pas que vous arrêtiez de
répondre à ses messages
parce que j'ai vu des messages qu'elle
vous envoyer encore aujourd'hui j'ai vu
tu me manques trop etc
mais est ce que c'est pour aider mon jeu
oui mais est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
n'êtes pas le plus mal placé pour
l'aider à se mobiliser c'est peut-être
le mal classé mais parce que c'est
vraiment c'est au fond d'elle c'est une
femme extraordinaire elle est c'est un
amour de 20 mo fondeurs et foutent sur
la gueule alors non mais non mais sur
aucune liste n'a pas qu'une femme est
mise à part cette petite gigue du mois
de février s'est jamais présenté
si la chose revenir sur quelque chose
aussi vous avez évacuer extrêmement
rapidement
là on parle de la violence physique et
vous avez dit tout à l'heure parce que
vous aviez évacuer les violences
physiques comme ça on n'en met pas
physique que verbale que verbale déjà
une violence verbale c'est une violence
on peut tuer quelqu'un avec les mots à
force de répéter à une femme que c'est
une merde ou l'arabe et ses plus bas que
terre c'est également une violence sans
être même titre il ya des coups qui ne
se voit pas et parlait mal à une femme à
longueur de journée l'insulté la
rabaisser c'est également un coup c'est
comme un coup de poing je sens que ça ne
se voit pas ces temps que c'est sale et
presque dire encore pire mais non dans
l'abjection n'ya pas n'y a pas de gamin
je suis d'accord mais laissez la
tranquille
alors ouais mon jeu était dur plus voilà
moi je ne crois pas voilà comme ça ça
c'est n'y crois pas c'est tout terrain
que déjà que tu dis oui je te dis une
chose
voilà maintenant répéter ça dites-moi ya
53 ans je suis marié ma femme et c'est
parce que c'est que je lui dise on
connaît tous qui vous l'a jamais un
mauvais roman à ma femme jamais toi tu
aimes ou que tu as peur de mal qui a
déjà filé d'état képi pape
je ne te crois pas alors tu as fait des
conneries instruments et ne va plus
d'avoir laissé le temps qui le tenait
c'est une envie d'aider loi n'a eu droit
samedi qu'il reconnaissait dans
l'assiette
comment on peut l'aider déjà mon disque
elle prend beaucoup de stupéfiants bon
alors voilà moi la première chose que je
comprends pas c est ce que c'est toi
si je peux me permettre fred qui a posté
ses photos avec d ecstasy ou des
substances illicites ou de la cocaïne
dans des visions que c'est moi j'ai payé
je voulais réveiller un peu les gens en
disant allez dans un état critique très
critique mois pour moi honnêtement elle
va au suicide avec toutes les drogues
qu'elle consomme aujourd'hui elle va au
suicide pour moi elle va au suicide mais
vous pensez vous réveiller les gens
passent au rouge et or des gens s'en
fichent de twitter un médecin mais quand
je dis les gens je parle aussi dans son
entourage famille à dire les nehalem
contact avec sa famille dans quelques
elle a très peu pendant ce temps
quelqu'un visiblement est en danger
puisque vous l'a côtoyé vous semblez
dire que vous la voyez c'est non
assistance à personne en danger
moi si je vois quelqu'un qui est en
danger je pense pas une photo sur
instagram je prends mon téléphone
j'appelle les pompiers les banques
rappelle quelqu'un qui peut l'aider
la route y reviennent tout l'été sur la
côte est qui les prenait c'était quoi
comment je vais pas les citer mais ce
n'est pas ce qu'on appelle à dents
longues et dures c'est pas du pastis
mais je crois parce que caçador dont il
ne me dit pas qui à kolonaki j'en ai
déjà consommé avec elle je la voulais
vraiment que je peux mais il faut que
vous disiez les choses aussi quand vous
avez posté les photos de drogue
volontairement c'était aussi pour
amoindrir votre responsabilité par
rapport à la gifle pour dire il ya un
environnement compliqué elle prend des
produits dans votre esprit peut-être que
vous avez vous calmer parce que c'était
une saison vous d'atténuer la
responsabilité peut-être aussi j'ai
peut-être si ces coûts ne sont pas de
vous est ce que vous vous portez plainte
contre lohan a pour 10 pharmacies mais
j'ai porté plainte pour diffamation
j'ai dans l'après midi même j'étais au
commissaire de police mais alors
pourquoi est-ce que c'est ccoo alors si
c'est par une journée des associations
je sais que il ya encore dix jours c'est
ce qualifier les bras c'est pas moins de
l'ag
b 1 j'ai pas été non plus lui scarifié
des éléments envoyés c'est vous croyez
que les gens ils croient votre version
je sais pas après moi je moi je sais la
vérité dans le chai rihanna main il y
aurait donc approché genre musical week
est dure et moi ce qui me fait bizarre
quand même c'est que vous êtes au
courant de toute sa vie dans les
moindres détails
et là il se passe quelque chose de très
grave sur elle et vous n'êtes pas au
courant de ce qui s'est passé c'est bien
ça après on peut s'attendre à tout avec
loana si ça peut être tout et n'importe
quoi au fait non non je n'en avais pas
dit parce que alors en fait ce qui vous
que vous sachiez c'est que elle dit que
c'était soit le 27 ou le 28 août dont
des social c'est pas très précis le 28
elle part à ont-ils déjà en vacances
donc moi si je me suis fait tabasser
pendant quatre heures je pète pas
forcément envie de partir en vacances
l'outrance et le 30
elle m'appelle parce qu'elle est dans un
besoin financièrement et je lui fais une
carte bleue aussi donc si vraiment
j'aurais été le coupé tous les liens
fina
faut vraiment qu'ils aient des gens qui
s'en occupent des amis elle qui la
prennent en charge
et même si on l'a d'or voilà monsieur
reid ou contactez moi si elle peut
répondre à mes messages
voilà ça serait vraiment un bonheur pour
nous de la prendre en main par en tout
cas de l'aider loana et giuly fred
franchement ce que vous avez fait c'est
inadmissible sans elle je reconnais